we want to handle this with love right
you want to tell him how his drug abuse
has hurt you and he hurt himself
okay Harold what time did you tell him
to be here five o'clock but he's always
late no he'll be here in three two one
this is a five o'clock free crack
giveaway
don't tell anybody I can
he's Tyrone
this week Tyrone gets invited to an
intervention hey okay Tyrone do you know
why crack crack hey Tyrone we are not
giving crack away today oh no time is it
it's 5 o'clock
did I miss a five o'clock free crack
giveaway these are your friends here
they have something they'd like to say
to you have a drink okay okay Tyrone I'm
what is known as an intervention
counselor oh yeah and these people would
like to talk to you about your drug use
what okay Rhonda Rhonda but this is
ridiculous what is going on in here
we got crack at the end Tyrone you know
I love you but I feel like drugs is
hurting you and that hurt me Tyrone I
was very hurt that you contact me that
time
what you told my letter I would never
call the police three hours later in my
car asleep how long crack that's
impossible Rhonda hackney sleep hey
daddy's little point okay I do that
wrong
Tyrone we opened our home to you you let
your addiction lead you to abuse our
trust Oh Janet Rock look you know it's
me talk I would never hurt you don't
play dumb with us Tyrone I remember the
whole speech I just need $200 I take
these rest day classes and I'm back on
my feet baby I'm serious Rob it's me
babies Tyrell I'm cleaning up man
okay give me y'all and could it be sorry
about this
I studied my ass off for that real
estate test we're off to my mother's be
back Sunday evening the number is on the
fridge if you need anything
parents Matisse and was a certified real
estate agent good for you Tyrone yeah
damn right good for him he sold our
house and kept the money four hundred
and fifty thousand dollars where's the
money Tyrone
he's spent it on a party took out an ad
for it the paper heart attack
I'll give you orders I'm gonna
restraining order gives you Harold all
right Tyrone I'm here because I love you
what have you learned so much Harold
why'd it get me fired from the post
office huh do you know how many people
on your route complain of receiving open
mail seven a hundred and thirty six
Tyrone and then there was the incident
with the powder
getting everybody be on the lookout for
any envelopes marks Senator Tom Daschle
or Tom Brokaw might contain anthrax
white powder and if it fell into the
wrong hands it could be big trouble
I got an tax mr. bomb baby 60 bucks if
that man hadn't turned you in it would
have been a disaster
y'all hack like crack is so bad we're
like the Good Book says let he who is
without sin
throwing the first rock and I shout
smoke f it basically Tyrone we would
like you to check into rehabilitation
immediately okay fine fine you know what
I need to get better y'all right but
first step is first I need to go to the
bathroom and then I'm on my way to
recovery Rhonda and that was me Rhonda
go to the bathroom okay I've got it from
here thank you I'll be right out oh oh -
ain't no windows in here